[Música]
del 1 al 10 cuánto creéis que os queréis
a vosotros mismos y a vosotras mismas
esto es una cosa que ellos lanzó buenos
días
me llamo maría y yo os voy a contar como
hasta hace dos años y medio prox tenía
una relación conmigo misma nefasta y me
quería como un -3 bien para esto os voy
a hacer un background muy escueto lo
vamos a experimentar pero creo que está
bien contextualizar os donde yo creo que
empezó este pensamiento negativo hacia
mi persona y que lo provocó no para eso
tendríamos que remontarnos al colegio
bueno pues como mucha gente por
desgracia mi época en el conexión no fue
un camino de rosas no fue una balsa de
aceite
recibía muchos comentarios negativos al
respecto de mi persona al respecto de mi
físico y todo tipo de comentarios todo
todo valía
bajita que si tenía demasiado vello en
el brazo me llamaban orejón porque rima
con mi apellido y yo tengo unas orejas
preciosas nunca tenía muy bien tampoco
tiene muy bien qué tipo de insulto es
ese no pero cuando eres tan pequeño no
entiende realmente el propósito de estas
cosas o no entiendes por qué te están
diciendo estas cosas pero acaban
anidando como en nuestra cabeza nuestro
subconsciente se quedan ahí y luego pues
años más tarde acaban volviendo no en
forma de fantasma forma como que te
persiguen y te acechan a ello al final
de esta época de mi vida lo pasé muy mal
pero también creo que es aquel mejor
aprendizaje que pude sacar o al menos lo
intente no hice lo que creía que tenía
que hacer intenté ser lo mejor o sacar
lo mejor de aquello y tirar para
adelante
dicho este contexto creo que es
suficiente para que entendáis un poco
donde yo creo que viene todo esto os voy
a hablar de la otra cosa que para mí es
fundamental en el tema del amor propio o
por lo que yo considero que para mí fue
lo más crítico en cuanto a ya tener una
mala relación conmigo misma y el por qué
y de dónde venía aquí son las redes
sociales aunque no lo parezca o creo que
no lo parece en unos pocos días yo
cumplo 30 años y cuando yo tenía redes
social empezaron las redes sociales y yo
era adolescente no eran como son ahora
vale teníamos messenger en tuenti
facebook fotolog y eran redes sociales
completamente distintas y además si tu
padre tu madre te tapaba el internet a
vino aún no había tu tía tú no hacías
nada no había una exposición como la que
hay ahora entonces claro ahora
estamos sometidos a una exposición 24/7
en instagram por ejemplo que es la red
de la que yo me voy a centrar porque
creo que al final es donde donde más
reside todo esto no estamos expuestos
24/7 a cuerpos de ensueño vidas de
ensueño pareja yo no como todo lo que
debería ser para ser maravilloso
perfecto triunfar que a todo esto
expuestos a vidas perfectas cuerpos
perfectos y de todo hemos estado siempre
lo que pasa es que era diferente porque
yo recuerdo por lo menos cuando yo era
más pequeña eran famosos no en los
factores las actrices deportistas
cantantes y son como personas a las que
por algún motivo consideramos que están
como en otro universo que no son
personas de verdad y que están ahí
entonces no les echamos tanta cuenta o
no nos produce tanta frustración no
tener vidas como las que tienen ellos
eso nos da como más igual porque es como
una cosa aspiracional pero puramente
platónica pero con instagram no con
instagram se genera una frustración muy
fuerte porque es un tú a tú' es un esta
vida que tienes la persona podría ser yo
o este cuerpo perfecto que tiene esta
persona en esta foto podría ser el mío y
no lo es esta pareja
tan de ensueño que todo es fantástico
podría ser la miel no lo es yo no tengo
esto y es la frustración constante de no
ser lo que se supone que es maravilloso
y lo que se supone que triunfa en redes
porque aparte esto es otra cosa que a mí
me parece muy peligroso y es que se ha
asociado el triunfar no el tener éxito
en la vida con los seguidores y con y
con ser ese tipo de personas en las
redes sociales yo creo que el éxito
súper relativo y para cada uno será una
cosa pero bueno entonces aquí es donde
donde empieza como una sociedad de
frustración brutal de no ser lo que se
espera que seas de no ser como esas
personas también os voy a decir una cosa
hasta el post que vosotros veis en
instagram para llegar a esa foto hay un
proceso de chapa y pintura de pulir y de
acera y bueno bueno un trabajo de
manualidades tremendo hasta que se ve
esa foto pero esas partes no la vemos
ahí es donde reside la importancia de
relativizar las redes sociales que luego
os contaré también considero que las
redes sociales aparte de generar este
momento de de inseguridad con nosotros
mismos porque no
no somos o creemos que no somos como lo
que se nos vende y que por ende no somos
válidos que tampoco sé muy bien quién
decide qué que es válido y que es bien y
que no yo eso no lo sé desde luego no lo
conozco pero me parece una quien
haya decidido esto y quien hace a la
gente creer que no es válido por no ser
lo que se ve pero os voy a decir que a
pesar de todo y aunque no lo parezca las
redes sociales tienen una parte muy
buena y es que han dado lugar a es una
plataforma para unas luchas sociales que
antes no llegaban a tanta gente hablamos
de cosas como el feminismo de cosas como
la lucha de la comunidad lgtb y estas
cosas ahora tienen una plataforma
espectacular que llegan a muchas más
personas y sobre todo a gente que están
en edades super vulnerables yo habría
agradecido muchísimo tener discursos
como estos cuando yo tenía 13 años
muchísimo por eso igual yo trato de ser
en mis redes sociales de esa manera y
mostrarme tal cual soy y ser lo más
natural que pueda para que esas personas
en esas edades tan vulnerables entiendan
que eso también existe en las redes
entonces claro que haya lugar para que
se reivindique e que seas como
de la manera que seas tengas el cuerpo
que tengas eres válido y eres válida es
increíble pero igual por estadística
cuando más grande su movimiento
cuanto más seguidores tienes cuanto
mejor lo estás haciendo también tienes
más detractores eso es así es una
lástima pero es así además es que los
haters son con un espécimen que está ahí
preparado para la lucha no está ahí
agazapado en un set o preparada que tú
subas cualquier cosa
y te va a teclear ahí toda la
frustración que tenga adentro bueno pues
cada uno gestiona su frustración de una
manera cómo te van a criticar hagas lo
que hagas y seas como seas y seas quién
decida ser chico por lo menos vive
felipe tranquilo
haz las cosas como quieras hacerlas
porque total meter contigo igual y esa
gente lo que pasa es que tiene cero
inteligencia emocional y cero empatía
para ellos porque al final los que van a
acabar perdiendo son ellos porque no son
capaces de ver o de aceptar que hay
gente que existe que quiere pero ahí
quiere ser feliz y mejorar en su vida de
una manera sana cada uno que haga las
cosas como quiera dicho esto por eso
creo que las redes sociales han generado
tanta inseguridad en nosotros porque
hemos visto cosas que nos han hecho
creer que teníamos que ser así para no
ser o sea para ser válidos y si no lo
éramos nos generaban está sensación de
hacerlos pequeñitos nuestra vida no era
así entonces teníamos muchas carencias a
mí por lo menos esto es lo que me pasó y
aquí es donde os voy a hablar de mi
batalla no con el amor propio para eso
es lo contextualizar también cómo voy a
hablar de mi última relación sentimental
porque creo al final que fue el
detonante para mí
pero han sido varias relaciones en mi
vida a las que yo he tenido
relaciones tóxicas que yo creo que aquí
creo que todo el mundo en algún momento
habremos tenido una relación tóxica o la
vamos a tener no pasa nada es humano
esas cosas pasan pero es importante
saber o por lo menos en mi caso yo sé
que todas esas relaciones y como yo
gestione eso vino muy condicionado a
como yo me sentía conmigo misma por
dentro y como yo tenía una relación de
tanta inseguridad conmigo de tanto miedo
lolo extrapolaba las relaciones que
tenía porque ahí es donde entra en juego
algo que es un un nudo aquí es la
dependencia emocional cuando tú estás
con alguien y tienes una relación
bastante mala contigo quieres o por lo
menos yo quería desde el miedo vale
quería desde el miedo a que la persona
con la que yo estaba me abandonaste no
me dejase y que cualquier persona que
pasase por delante fuese mejor que yo
es horrible verbalizar lo horrible pero
es la verdad yo tenía muchísimo miedo yo
sentía que pues eso que cualquier cosa
que yo hacía estaba mal que cualquier
cosa que yo pudiese decirle cómo me
sentía iba a hacer que me dejase
era horrible y además estás cargando de
responsabilidad de esa persona y es una
responsabilidad que no tiene no tiene
por qué lidiar con estas cosas y al
final cuando te sientas y te das cuenta
de que cuando tú a ti mismo te das el
cariño y el respeto que te mereces esto
cambia porque
claro a ver el catalizador para mí fue
la ruptura no yo deposite todo mi amor
en esta persona con la que yo estaba
quiero dejar esto muy claro yo no estoy
diciendo que cuando tenemos una relación
negativa con nosotros mismos no queramos
a los demás no lo que estoy diciendo es
que en mi caso el lugar desde donde yo
quería no era bueno porque insisto
quería desde el miedo y eso fue muy
problemático para mí porque en el
momento en el que se acabó la relación
porque sorpresa esas cosas pasan las
relaciones se pueden acabar las
relaciones de amistad de pareja incluso
familiares pueden llegar a fin y no pasa
es ley de vida habrá gente que esté
contigo siempre habrá gente que se
marche y no pasa nada pero es que la
única persona que va a estar contigo
toda la vida eres tú vamos a hacer un
poquito de ejercicio para estar bien con
nosotros mismos digo yo porque nos vamos
a tener que aguantar toda una vida
entonces bueno cuando esta persona y yo
rompimos la relación yo me quedé
destruida en mil pedazos destruida y yo
todo el rato en mi cabeza me alimentaba
no me ha dejado porque no soy suficiente
me ha dejado porque porque no era lo
suficientemente válida por esto por lo
otro todo era una flagelación porque
esas otras vivimos en la sociedad de la
comparación y de la flagelación es una
cosa y entonces ya dije vale maría hasta
aquí hemos tocado fondo a partir de aquí
hay que aprender a tirar p'alante porque
si no porque yo me sentía que estaba
solís y macario no contaba conmigo misma
porque siempre me había despreciado y
pues empecé hacer un ejercicio conmigo
misma que parece una chorrada ha contado
pero para mí fue sanador y muy difícil
de hacer yo todos los días
y me senté
en la cama me miraba en el espejo y
durante media hora de reloj cronometrada
me decía a mí misma todo lo que yo
odiaba de mí alak verbalizado horrible
horrible porque de mí han hablado muy
mal y siguen hablando muy mal y hablarán
muy mal porque insisto haters tendremos
todos y siempre va a haber pero las
peores cosas me las he dicho yo y cuando
yo verbalizaba esas cosas en alto
mirándome al espejo mirándome a mí a la
cara pensaba
dios cómo puedo estar diciendo me yo es
misma que soy la que me está dando la
vida no la que me permite estar viva y
me estoy diciendo estas barbaridades
entonces poco a poco iba hablándome a mí
y cada vez tenía menos cosas que decir
cada vez tenía menos cosas que decir
pensaba mis estrías que me hacías y el
brazo digo y eso cuál es el problema no
entiendo muy bien por qué pasa y acabé
dándome cuenta de que no de que yo era
maravillosa de que era muy válida y me
volví a construir desde el principio y
entonces fue un camino muy duro insisto
he contado parece así pero no fue muy
largo y me di cuenta de que desde ese
momento las relaciones que yo tenía de
amistad de amor
eran desde un lugar maravilloso porque
no podemos pretender que nuestra
felicidad dependa de otras personas
porque esas personas insisto se pueden
ir en cualquier momento y qué vamos a
hacer no puede ser que nuestra felicidad
dependa de personas externas pueden
complementar nuestra felicidad pueden
acompañarnos en un camino
en el camino de nuestra vida a cogernos
de la mano pero no podemos depositar esa
responsabilidad y esa carga emocional en
esas personas ni podemos permitir ser la
responsabilidad emocional de otros
entonces cuando yo aprendí esto yo me
liberé y eso me ha ayudado a lo que para
mí es lo más importante y que por eso se
contextualizado las redes sociales es a
relativizar las redes sociales para
empezar si tú crees que el ver las redes
sociales y lo que eso te genera es
problemático deja de consumirlas al
menos un tiempo hasta que tú te des
cuenta de que estás mejor pero si las
consumes hazlo desde un lugar de
fenomenal te admiro me encanta lo que me
enseñas me encanta lo que haces pero no
de un si no soy eso es que no soy válido
de verdad dejar de darle credibilidad
ese discurso casposo no sí que lo ha
decidido pero a la o sea ya está
sois válidos sois válidas todos lo somos
y sobre todo porque todo eso que creéis
que es tan perfecto y esas personas que
vemos pues que son tan perfectas no son
perfectas nadie lo es y todos tenemos
problemas absoluta
todos y a cabo contamos porque es una
cosa que me resulta muy particular y por
eso me llamaba tanto la atención a mí en
todo este camino que yo he hecho con el
amor propio y todo yo soy muy de a mí
antes me daba una ansiedad mostrar mi
cuerpo y mostrarme yo porque pensaba que
era todo lo feo tengo estrías celulitis
tengo mis lorzas mis cosas y me daba
como el cómo voy a mostrar esto ahora ya
me da igual y el haberlo hecho y empezar
a mostrarlo y recibir mensajes tan
bonitos como los que recibo de gente
diciéndome lo muchísimo que les ha
ayudado esto lo muchísimo que les ayuda
ver a alguien mostrar su cuerpo digo
pues éste tampoco mostrar otro porque
este es el que yo tengo angelina jolie
enseña el suyo pues yo enseño el mío que
hago yo si yo no soy angelina jolie por
lo siento de mis bienes que eres muy
valiente
chica valiente pues es que son mis
chicas tendría que enseñar las no puedo
hacer otra cosa tengo tiempo de pulir
mis fotos dos ratos y luego me vas a ver
y vas a decir mal mentido y yo
papilla lo siento pues no chico yo ya
voy pa lante como los de alicate y ya
está entonces de verdad para no pensar
en eso porque a mí me mandan mensajes
diciéndome eso que soy muy valiente que
muchísimas gracias por hacer lo que hago
que me ven divina que desprende luz que
desde hace mucho tiempo me ven mucho más
feliz porque son gente que ha estado
conmigo en las redes durante muchísimo
tiempo que qué maravilla que ojalá ellos
que ojalá a ellas y yo les escribí les
digo vale muchísimas gracias pero como
que ojalá yo si tú me ves a mí y me
llamas valiente por mostrar mi cuerpo
tal cual es y tú mismo me estás diciendo
que tienes un cuerpo muy parecido al
tuyo y siempre está acomplejado pero me
ves a mí te encanta si tú que me
escribes a mí un mensaje que no me
conoces diciéndome que admiras muchísimo
lo que hago que me ves y que doy que
transmito luz que me ves maravillosa que
estoy venda que se me nota muchísimo el
trabajo que he hecho conmigo si me
mandan esos mensajes esas personas y son
capaces de verlo en mí que no me conocen
yo les digo como no vais a ser capaces
de verlo en vosotros que os dais la vida
de todos los días os levantáis
y queréis a vuestros amigos y queréis a
la gente que queréis y tenéis una vida
gracias a vuestro cuerpo amad el cuerpo
que tenéis porque es un templo no lo
derribé jce con piedras en base a
discursos de gente que no conocéis de
nada porque no tiene ningún sentido así
que eso es lo que os puedo decir que de
verdad creo que para mí ha sido me ha
cambiado la vida
el quererme sobre todo porque me ha dado
pie a entender que nadie insisto es
perfecto que todos tienen problemas que
hasta las personas que crees que son más
perfectos tienen sus complejos y son
completamente válidos no hay que
desmerecer a nadie porque creamos que
esa persona no puede tener complejos con
el cuerpo que tiene como los tiene y no
hay que intentar justificar no cada uno
tiene su batalla y al fin de webb este
acabaré diciendo que es que todo el
mundo es perfectamente imperfecto
[Aplausos]